انظر الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي صواريخ بعيده المدى عاتبه
اخرى تتخطى تصليح الغربي لاوكرانيا بجانب
تدريب على اف 16 بجانب ضمانات امنيه بعيده
المدى من الدول السبع الكبرى لاوكرانيا
كيف سنعكس ذلك على
هذه الحرب الدائره والهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد
اضافيه لاوكرانيا لانه عندما نتحدث الان
عن منظومات الصواريخ كانت
الصواريخ 80 كيلو متر وادى الدور فاعل جدا
في معركه خاركف وخرسن وغير ذلك الان
عمليات الصواريخ
صواريخ ستايل صواريخ اتى كامز نتحدث عن
250 و300 كيلو متر اذا بمعنى اخر تطال
كافه جبر الجغرافيا جغرافيا الاراضي
الاوكرانيه التي تم احتلالها بما فيها
جزيره القرم
وتطال خطوط الامداد ضمن هذه المناطق هذه
اول نقطه اضافيه الان الحديث عن احتماليه
التزويد بصواريخ ضد الجو وان كانت اقل
سويه من التاكيد على الصواريخ ارض ارض او
جو ارض يضاف الى ذلك تدريب الطيارين نعم
ياخذ وقت ولكن
من المؤكد ان كافه العناصر التي سيتم
تدريبها هي ليست عناصر لا تملك الخلفيه لا
هؤلاء يجب ان يكونوا طيارين على طائرات
سوفيتيه او روسيه حسب الموجود سوخوي او
غيرها طائرات كذلك اطقم المسانده الاطقم
المسانده لعمل الطائره والطيار وهم على
نفس الاهميه من تاهيل التيار من المؤكد
لديهم خبرات اذا الان هو عمليه تعزيز هذه
الخبرات بالتدريب على سلاح جديد واذا ما
وصلت هذه الطائرات ستحقق في الحد الادنى
التفوق الجوي المحلي ان لم تستطيع ان تحقق
سيطره جويه او تفوق جوي في مسرح العمليات
على الاقل تستطيع ان تقدم الاسناد الجوي
والحمايه الجويه المحليه مما يحد من
القدرات الروسيه على استخدام الطائرات او
استخدام الصواريخ اذا هي عباره عن اوراق
اضافيه تعزز القدره الاوكرانيه لانجاح
هجومها المضاد طيب يعني اشرت الى الهجوم
المضاده الجميع يتذكر ما قيل عن طائرات
الاف سته عشر وانت اخبر مني في هذا الاطار
ولكن قيل بانها تحتاج الى مدايات طويله
لكي تنطلق وبالتالي مما يجعلها اهداف الى
حد ما سهله نحن نتحدث عن الهجوم المضاد
هذا الهجوم وزير الدفاع يقول بانه لم يبدا
بعد بل نحن في مرحله التحضير كل ما يجري
حول هذا الهجوم وتزويد اوكرانيا بكل هذه
الاسلحه انا ينبئ وكانه هنالك تعثر في
مرحله ما ان هنالك لم يحقق او لم تحقق هذه
التحضيرات المبتغى منها
اذا اخذنا بحرفيه التصريح الاوكراني ان
هذه هي المرحله التمهيديه وقلنا قبل ان
يقول ذلك لا نتصور من خلال حجم القوات
وطبيعه العمليات ان ما يجري خلال الاسابيع
الاولى ان هذا الهجوم الرئيسي واذا كان
التعرض الرئيسي فهذا يعني ان المعلومات
التي قدمت عن القدرات هي معلومات مضلله
وبالتالي يجب ان يكون الهجوم التمهيدي لان
له اهداف محدده اختصرها في جمله واحده
تهيئه الارضيه العملياتيه لانجاح الهجوم
الرئيسي من سواء من
تحقق جزئيا تحقق جزئيا لانه تم السيطره
على اكثر من 130 الى 140 كيلو متر تم
تحديد بعض النقاط الضعف تم احداث اختراقات
سواء في منطقه جبروجيا في ملتقى الحدود
جبروجيا مع دونيس او في شمال وجنوب ضخمه
تحديدا اذا هناك نجاحات لكن هذه النجاحات
لا ترقى الى المستوى الذي يسمح
عملياتيا باطلاق الهجوم لانه لا تزال لا
يزال القتال في خط الدفاع الاول ماذا عن
المناطق التي يوجد بها ثلاثه خطوط دفاعيه
بين الخط والاخر 20 كيلومتر خاصه في منطقه
توكماك ومحيط دونيسك اذا دعيني اقول
الهجوم نجح جزئيا لم يحقق المطلوب منه ولم
يحقق التوقعات وان كان على اعتبار انها
المرحله التمهيديه
شكرا لك لواء فايزه الخبير العسكريه
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان